après un marathon de 29 jours que même
la fumée n'a pas trop semblé perturbé
les deux chefs s'apprêtent à passer le
fil d'arrivée
la chef du Parti conservateur Uni a
choisi de conclure sa campagne à Calgary
vendredi entouré de quelques candidats
et la réitéré le message maintes fois
répété au cours des dernières semaines
a plutôt opté pour une série de benful
et à chaque arrêt elle s'est présentée
comme la meilleure option pour la
stabilité de l'Alberta remettant en
doute la compétence de sa rivale
que ce soit les feux de forêt le rapport
accablant de la commissaire haltique sur
l'ingérence de Daniel Smith dans le
système de justice ou le débat des chefs
rien assemblé faire dérailler le plan de
campagne des deux principaux partis
l'économie la santé et la sécurité
publique ont dominé les débats malgré
les feux le climat et l'environnement
ont très peu été abordés c'est resté
serré tout le long de la campagne et là
on va sortir la campagne puis c'est
encore pas clair qui a pris le dessus
qui a réussi à tirer son épine du jeu
Daniel Smith c'est montrer discipliné et
la souvent esquivé les attaques et
défendues les valeurs conservatrices
donc de limiter les dommages qu'elle
pourrait faire à son propre parti a été
probablement le mot d'ordre beaucoup de
conservateurs vont probablement se
pincer le nez pour aller voter le 29 mai
sachant que d'une certaine façon ça va
mettre dernière semaine comme première
ministre mais dans le fond la loyauté
envers le Parti est plus importante dans
le fond que les gens qui le dirigent les
néo-démocrates ont plutôt opté pour la
stratégie inverse mise en tout au long
de la campagne sur l'image de leur chef
a décidé d'y mettre du sien axis
demeure la grande inconnue ville aux
idées progressistes mais au cœur
profondément conservateur c'est dans la
métropole que le résultat de l'élection
risque de se jouer